a lot of people have been asking me what
is World Economic Forum all about there
can be not one single answer but if you
ask me it is a wonderful platform to
bring industry government social and
developers and use all together idea is
that they look at each other's issues
each other's interpretation of what is
pleasing the world economy and come up
with alternative solutions the key word
is out of box thinking you cannot be
rigid that what I am saying is true and
what everybody else is saying is false
we have to understand because everybody
has a viewpoint on how to solve the
problems of the world and the beauty
about India economic summit is that it
has brought together more focused
representation from India so we have
representatives of the Union government
the state government is represented at
the highest level both elected
representatives and the civil service
plus highest echelons of Industry and
the corporate sector is represented
supported by participation of NGOs
participation of social entrepreneurs
who are trying to alleviate economic
issues facing our country there are
alternatives and there are alternatives
there is no one solution which fits all
problems the idea is we all come
together and see how best we can move
forward either straight forward
sometimes you move sideways to find a
solution and then again move forward
idea is an alternate optimal approach
and that is the message I take back from
here
two of us